at the end of the day there's nothing
really intrinsically redeeming about
anime I mean no more than any other type
of media they're ultimately just TV
shows from Japan that said the metas
onra has some unique forms and story
templates that are either uncommon or
functionally non-existent in Western
media and that's worth singling anime
out for exploration
it's a pulpy format often cheaply made
heavy on formula low on critical respect
and low on scrutiny it's that last note
that's important though I'll have to
explain what I really mean by that a TV
show like two and a Half Men or a Disney
film like The Lion King those are highly
scrutinized for marketability just just
in case you were worried it was artistic
scrutiny a lot of money and reputation
is at stake so the authors end up
surrounded by circles of lawyers image
managers network executives studio
executives marketers and the bosses of
all of those people all taking stake in
the product the shows are workshops and
focus-grouped consultants are brought in
and in the end there are a lot of people
who are paying attention to what's going
on in order to make sure that the end
product serves their ultimate goal of
making a boatload of cash that's why we
talk about animators sneaking things
past the censors pulpy formats on the
other hand no one really cares about at
least not in specific there are still
stakeholders involved but they tend to
be more concerned with the overall
package than any given piece so long as
you're hitting the main selling points
of the formula you're golden does your
romance novel have a vulnerable heroine
with a heaving bosom does it have a dark
stranger with a mysterious past rippling
pecs and a heart of gold
bent fine whoever the hell you want else
with it this lack of oversight combined
with let's face it generally low
expectations both of the audience and
from the audience
make pulp formats one of the best places
for authors to explore in arthur c
clarke HP Lovecraft film noir and most
of our modern comic book superheroes
have their roots in low-grade pulp
indie games and web comics would be the
newest comparable formats all of these
pulpy formats have the same thing in
common
tons and tons of forget ibly low-grade
crap with the occasional piece that
experiments in a way that just works the
quantity over quality approach gives a
lot of different people opportunities to
push something out there it gives them
off
used to fail to learn and if they're
willing to try to innovate the barriers
for entry are low and turnover is high
anime isn't all that different the vast
majority is forgettable formula crap fat
at best
feign some maudlin depth but there's
also some really interesting really
inventive really funny really resonant
and really charming stuff being made and
with that preamble let's talk about neon
genesis evangelion the end of Evangelion
you
to start the end of evangelion is one of
the greatest troll moments in modern
history so let's talk about it the end
of Evangelion is reduce EO ad absurdum
are reduction to the absurd but that
doesn't really do it credit it is Hideo
ki anno standing naked atop a mountain
at dawn dick flapping in the wind as he
gives the Double Deuce action to a
notion of fanboys the film itself is
okay has some interesting artistic
merits and make some narrative choices
that bear discussion but all of that
pales in comparison to the discussion
about the story surrounding the film at
this point the story has been worked
over so many times that is practically
myth but I like this mythology both
because it reinforces my worldview and
because it's entertaining first we have
to talk about the show and how the show
actually ended Neon Genesis Evangelion
is a combination subversion and
evolution of the giant fighting robot
genre of anime as the name of the genre
implies giant fighting robot shows
typically revolved around giant robots
that fight the roots of the genre go all
the way back to the 50s with Tetsu and
28th go known in English countries as
Gigantor or Iron Man 28 but audiences
are far more familiar with shows like
Matt cross Gundam or the Japanese
American co-production Robotech which is
itself a spin-off slash mutation of Matt
cross and has its own All American child
in the MechWarrior franchise Evangelion
starts off ordinary enough if a little
bleak but the first 10 episodes are more
or less rote giant fighting robot stuff
the only thing sort of innovative was
the odd design of the robots as somewhat
horrific organic machine hybrids and a
heavy injection of Christian mythology
and symbology which added a distinct
supernatural element that was at the
least a bit unique actually small
tangent here just because it's
interesting but doesn't really pay off
anywhere else the use of Christian
mythology is often touted by a chunk of
the Western fan base as a dense and
obtuse metaphor a deeply rooted
commentary and criticism of metaphysics
the reality is that the predominantly
Shinto Buddhist Japanese authors of
Evangelion use Christianity in the same
way that we use North's and Roman
mythology
back on track after episode 10 things
started to shift with less and less time
for episode being spent dealing with the
monster of the week and then around
episode 16 things really changed deeply
the root causes we're both scheduling
changes made within the studio that
significantly reduced the time given to
create each episode and the sarin gas
attack on this Tokyo subway system in
March 1995 the compelled anno to drop a
chunk of completed work that resembled
the real-life event actually I feel like
I need to expand a little bit more on
why gainax was willing to adjust their
course following the attacks
unfortunately the events were a little
bit more than superficial in their
similarities the attack on the Tokyo
subway system was perpetrated by a
doomsday cult that drew heavily on
Christian imagery and mythology in fact
the entire purpose of the attack in
their minds was to hasten the oncoming
apocalypse given that Evangelion also
features a shadowy government group
seeking to bring about the end of the
world by initiating the apocalypse I
don't really blame Gainax for getting a
little bit gun-shy these sudden changes
applied a ton of pressure and left big
voids that needed to be filled at a time
when everyone was desperate to have a
product shipping out the door to other
ingredients to add to the stew Anna had
spent at least four years prior to the
production of Evangelion in a state of
deep depression and during the
production he'd become increasingly
disenchanted with the otaku or hyper fan
lifestyle the final 10 episodes of
Evangelion and by extension the entire
show due to how these episodes are
reframed the early narrative are a story
about depression the critical role of
self-acceptance in identity in the toxic
nature of obsession and fixation through
the show the writers demonstrate often
in harsh and abrasive ways that no one
can really rely on others for their
self-identity friends colleagues
authority figures the government your
job even lovers and family none of them
are a replacement for self-worth because
at the end of the day other people have
their own things to worry about
shinji's life is an unending cascade of
failures that drive home this point
the one thing that shinji wants most in
his life is
validation of who he is as a person and
one by one these things are taken away
from him no matter how hard he tries to
impress his father his father remains
distant his friendships and work
relationships often let him down if he's
not outright robbed of them his job
betrays him and the status that he gets
from being important ultimately makes
him a target and becomes a liability in
the end shinji is stripped of everything
this is represented literally and
figuratively by the end of the world the
last two episodes of the series revolve
around the end of the world and the
transformative process that shinji goes
through as he has finally locked away
with nothing but himself and forced to
confront his own existence
it's not until Shinji accepts who he is
that he is a thing that exists and that
existing is on its own power it's not
until he stops relying on the rest of
the world to support his full wait stops
relying on the rest of the world to give
him meaning that these other
relationships flow into existence the
explicit message of the show is that no
one else can live your life for you it's
about making that breakthrough and
recovering from depression where you
realize that you have value and power
over your own life and that what you get
from relationships is intrinsically tied
to what you give the messages that
identity and acceptance are things that
come from within and flow out into the
world not things that you can pull out
of the world and crammed inside relying
on everyone else can work for a time but
it will never last because things happen
other people have their own problems
they get sick they die they move away
their priorities change you are the only
person who will be there for every
moment of your entire life
this message is presented somewhat
abstractly through narrative line
animation and montage but it's actually
quite effective at telling the story
that it wants to tell the lack of budget
in time forced them to try something out
of the box and what they came up with
mesh is incredibly well with the overall
message I mean let's take one specific
example just to demonstrate when shinji
has his epiphany that he wants to live
this force of personality this change in
perception literally radiates outwards
from him and redefines his experiential
world as it passes this ending about the
end of the world the one that ultimately
focuses on the microcosmic spiritual
salvation of the prototype
in a very direct and personal way
recontextualizes the preceding episodes
in a way that elevates the show above
every other action drama and aside from
art direction it is what ultimately
makes Ava noteworthy and fans hated it
they sent death threats to a no like
actual death threats they didn't want
all this metaphor and meaning they
wanted giant robots they wanted more
Aska being sexy they wanted more
fighting they wanted more Rey being
strange and aloof and sexy they wanted
Shinji their avatar and surrogate to get
everything he ever wanted they wanted
more crazy more pseudo religious imagery
more about nerve and eighty fields and
instrumentality on seal they wanted more
so anno gave them more he gave them a
twisted perversion of everything they
wanted he took their entitled fanboy ISM
and threw it right back in their faces
in the least subtle way possible Shinji
masturbates to completion over ask his
comatose body
and that's just the starting point and
with that let's take another diversion
outer theory is a load of crap that
still contains some valid observations
in as much as the author is also the
audience effectively implying the
creationist communication not
Aristotelian pedagogy personally I think
the out to our theory was drafted up by
a bunch of prima donnas who just didn't
like working with others great things
are made by individuals but they
certainly don't have any sort of
monopoly some people work well alone
some people work well in groups and when
it comes to meaning in the end only
audience remains that said content
creators aren't totally out of the
picture and an artist's intent is worth
perhaps a dollar more than a random
person's but unless the narrative
happens to grab on to some portion of
conversation about intent and the back
and forth between creators and audience
then all of that gets lost to the sands
of time intent is useful trivia as a
litmus test for the final product there
is debate about whether or not the end
of Ava's revenge against the ultra fans
or not some defend the film as though
this was the vision all along in the
broadcast episodes were deep compromise
that everyone was unhappy with that well
that sounds like something said by
someone who wasn't really paying
attention I mean let's not sugarcoat
this Shinji masturbates to completion
over a SCA's comatose body
here's how it breaks down on one hand we
have the broadcast ending of the show
which spends two episodes convincing the
main character that he can only truly
connect with the people around him only
truly achieve unity with everyone else
only become a productive and creative
force in the universe once he has
learned to take responsibility for
existence once he has decided that he
wants to live so da okobogee the sky
on the other hand we have end of Ava
where the main character does nothing
learns nothing realizes nothing and
accomplishes nothing well he does
masturbate to completion over ask his
comatose body so I guess he does have at
least one climax when presented with a
choice he rejects unity rejects
understanding and rejects love this is
the polar opposite story in fact okay
India Evangelion mythos there's
something called an et field which is an
absolute terror field don't worry about
the specifics the idea is that living
things meaning humanity are individuals
because their fear creates a barrier
between their ego and everyone else's
ego basically it's my fear of being hurt
that keeps me from truly you know
connecting with other people what
convinces Shinji to restart humanity in
end of Evangelion isn't some notion that
individuality is valuable and suffering
allows us to appreciate great beauty
it's the notion that other people will
feel fear again he's so caught up in his
own misery and pain that he just wants
other people to suffer too so the
universe gives him Aska back and he
immediately tries to choke her to death
but he can't even do that because he's
ultimately too weak and impotent in the
universe to make any kind of meaningful
decision that's bleak but I'll concede
that it's messy so let's break it out
into three considerations consideration
one the broadcast version is the
intended capstone of the show in
consideration one we end with a message
about hope self-acceptance
self-sacrifice unity and over
humming depression the ava's and the
angels of the show become metaphors for
the things in our lives that are just so
much bigger than us that they seem
almost unmanageable
in fact the Ava's themselves reveal to
be biological robots powered by the
souls of the kids dead parents mostly
their mothers
are essentially a metaphor for adulthood
all kids are asked to grow into the
legacy of their parents which involves
confronting and accepting both the good
and the bad
realizing that our parents are human too
is a big step in maturing into adulthood
and when you're a teenager it's kind of
overwhelming and hard to comprehend you
have this fiery passion for life but the
world is still so much bigger than you
the Angels are the adult problems
they're going to get thrown your way
whether you're prepared or not and
growing into adulthood is essentially a
little more than confronting these
problems and learning to pilot an adult
body consideration to the end of ava is
the intended capstone of the show in
consideration - we end with a story
about a bleak failure of a human being
confronted with challenges that he was
not prepared for could not cope with and
was ultimately crushed by he is
marginally aware of his own failings and
immaturity emotionally physically and
sexually but in the end is consumed by
them and chooses to isolate himself from
everyone else when given what is
ostensibly the object of his desire he
tries to destroy it because he is an
irredeemable ruined husk of a human
being
you
certainly a far darker character arc and
a much bleaker story overall but given
the events that immediately precede both
endings where Shinji is forced to kill
the one person in the world who loves
him unconditionally it really could go
either way
consideration three if consideration two
is true does that prevent end of Ava
from being revenge
you know what no it doesn't it can be
both at the same time in essence the
question of whether or not end of Ava is
revenge is separate from the question
about the intended ending of the show
because the revenge elements can be
isolated from the overall plot and
events of the story the revenge comes in
the specifics the major criticism of
hyper fans stems from how their
obsession over certain elements stunts
their growth and narrows their vision
let's not mince words they tend to be
sexual perverts see it's not about
really really liking something it's
about obsession and entitlement and end
of Ava injects both in spades for one
Shinji masturbates to completion over
ask his comatose body
I keep saying that because I want it to
sink in just how overt that is as a
condemnation of the objectifying
possessive and sexualized attitude mega
fans exhibit towards female characters
fanservice is practically a cornerstone
of otaku culture and this is no
different in the North American
equivalents which is why I've just been
saying mega fan instead of otaku
remember shinji is was and always will
be the intended audience surrogate the
opening 10 episodes are practically by
the numbers magic boy pilots giant
robots story he was the audience
surrogate for the first 10 episodes he
was the audience surrogate for the
following 16 why should he stop now why
would he stop now at what point did he
stop the point where you started feeling
icky about yourself with that in mind
there's a specific sequence we should
look at at the 1 hour mark the world
effectively ends Orwell is right on the
cusp of ending and shinji ziggo begins
to dissolve this begins a dissection of
Shinji as a character first dealing with
his childish impulsiveness and
abandonment issues in a vignette
involving a sand castle and second
dealing with his relationships with
women in an eight-minute long sequence
the female members of the cast run down
Shinji in what can only be described as
a brutal of Visser ation of his views on
women his jealousy is possessiveness and
most of all his unwillingness to take
responsibility for his role in the
relationships the use of montage and
selective framing in this sequence is
brilliant we are shown the world through
Shinji's eyes his gaze his view of the
women in his life which is for the most
part their breasts neck legs and asses
basically every kind of fanservice shot
shows up here as a weapon of
condemnation against the protagonist
because on one hand we are given his
view of the world but simultaneously he
is confronted by the voices of the women
he objectifies and they bring him to
task for this he watches bitterly and
disbelievingly as Masato has sex she
tells him to deal with it Aska tells him
he'll never understand her well Shinji
focuses on her breasts and ass he
complains that she never talks to him so
how can you understand ray asks if he
ever really tried to understand
he of course defends himself and insists
that he did then ask it cuts right to
the bone I know all about your little
jerk-off fantasies
so Shinji changes his tune and blames
them why can't you be nice to me they
tell him they are nice to him and he
flips out Shinji launches into a rant
about how they're all just toying with
him hiding behind those smiles and
keeping things ambiguous note that at
this point it's not even specific the
three women aren't even individualized
despite the very different relationships
and conflicts that he has with each of
them too Shinji they're just the objects
of his sexual desire when they say hey
[ __ ] things about us are ambiguous
because we've got our own crap to deal
with he complains about how that makes
his life hard in the last part of the
sequence he hones in on ask again and
basically cries like a spoiled child he
insists that only she can help him he
needs her to love him and here we go
with the grand summation of Shinji as a
character in the condemnation of the
audience through him as a surrogate
he doesn't need Aska anyone will do he's
only honed in on her because he's afraid
of everyone else unwilling to try
unwilling to grow unwilling to love
himself and unwilling to accept what
life brings him she's got him there
really he's full of self-loathing and he
doesn't need her not specifically he
doesn't actually care about her I mean
he did masturbate to completion over her
comatose body and that's just really
difficult to defend lacking any ground
to stand on Shinji loses it
you
and then everyone melts into tang okay
wrap this all up okay to wrap this all
up why do I care if end of evangelion
is in whole or in part revenge against
the otaku that decried the ending of the
show well mostly because that's an
interesting story on its own it's modern
folklore and create some interesting
variations in how you can approach and
interpret the film namely I like how it
frames the relationship between authors
and audience an author's interpretation
of their own work in the widest scope of
things isn't much truer than anyone
else's interpretation but what if it's
not just conflict of interpretations
what if the process of creation is
direct communication conversation
between author and audience Oh both
acknowledges and invites the audience to
acknowledge the audience author membrane
as part of the movie itself at one point
the film breaks the fourth wall and
displays fan mail both positive and
negative that was sent to Gainax as well
as vandalism on the gainax studio
entryway they explicitly acknowledge yes
we hear you the two different endings to
the show the broadcast and the movie
give us two different visualizations of
the same critical character moment with
drastically different outcomes why the
shift from a story of self-discovery to
one of total failure why did Shinji's
fate shift so dramatically
well shinji is the audience surrogate I
guess we know what anno thinks of his
audience
yeah
you